president joe biden is going to brief uh
the country on the state of our union
and today i'm going to brief you about
the state of the david pakman show it's
it's been an incredible year um the
second year of the coveted pandemic the
first year of joe biden's presidency
economic uncertainty vaccines inflation
other calamities 2021 was an incredibly
strong year from the standpoint of the
show
and i can report to you that the state
of the david pakman show is very very
strong some say the best that we've seen
um in 2021 we added more than 200 000
youtube subscribers not the most we've
ever added in a year but the most we've
ever added in a non-election year uh and
that is now putting us within striking
distance of 1.5
million youtube subscribers
our friends over at the young turks have
been really the standard bearers for
left-wing youtube channels for a very
long time
and i can report to you with total peace
and love that in the last few months the
david pakman show youtube channel is
receiving more daily views than the
young turks main channel friendly
competition their network is way bigger
than ours we love everybody over there
but just a reminder with a small team
you can do some pretty amazing things
in terms of the audio podcast monthly
downloads are now at their historic peak
our previous peak was that crazy period
between the november 2020 election and
the trump riots that was our high water
mark
we are at a new high water mark now with
the audio podcast
the most downloads a month in the
history of the show
we've got new platforms quickly growing
nearly a hundred thousand followers on
instagram nearly a hundred thousand
followers on tick tock we've launched
youtube shorts content instagram reels
content 2021 also saw the return of the
david pakman show town hall events
hugely popular with our core audience
but
the year was not without some major
challenges
we received the 90-day monetization ban
from facebook after our content was
wrongly flagged for spreading covered
disinformation something we would never
do but it was a big hit to our revenue
thanks to the hard work of nearly a
dozen facebook employees who are in our
audience we were able to get that
monetization ban reversed in under a
month but it's a stark reminder of how
precarious these revenue sources are
more recently we got a 24-hour ban and a
community guidelines strike on tick-tock
due to another false positive in a
segment where we criticize right-wing
actor kevin sorbo and his opinion about
healthcare we were banned for 24 hours
and now one strike closer
to a permanent ban from tick-tock and of
course we were targeted by right wing
conspiracy theorist alex jones who
launched a brutal attack on my
appearance on my eyes on my face
discharged a number of salvos against
our bonus show
so we are up against some major
obstacles
obstacles in attempting to move towards
a sort of more media literate critically
thinking society donald trump continues
to deliver these erratic febrile screeds
on a regular basis his followers love it
fox news continues to spread
disinformation sometimes spending 24
even 48 hours talking about
hillary clinton must soon be going to
prison given all the crimes she
supposedly committed just boogeymen
boogeymen of critical race theory
cancellations dr seuss it's pervading
right-wing media and their followers
fall for it
a seemingly on speed don jr regularly
inciting the most bottom dwelling pond
scum of the political right in these
apoplectic froths
over misunderstandings and distortions
and that's not going to stop
sadly and it is sad
even some on the left fall for the
disinformation many so-called leftists
wildly attacking me for being a supposed
imperialist bastard despite my constant
refrains that i am against american
intervention abroad in almost all cases
the facts do not matter to too many
people
but
we will not give up and we will continue
to persevere because i see the good
in the independent media audience i see
it in that 15 year old canadian kid who
recently called in inspired so many of
you
with his wit and his intelligence and
his curiosity i see it in the people
emailing me 20 30 40 times every day
even though their emails have been
filtered into the trash for months
they're still enthusiastically emailing
me
i see it even in the right wing troll
callers who we know
are calling constantly because they see
us having an impact that's why they
won't stop leaving me voicemails they're
worried
that we're talking sense and that people
are understanding it
that's the david pakman show i know and
that's why i can confidently tell you
today the state of the union no the
state of the show is as strong as ever
and it makes me hopeful about the future
of independent media thank you
and god bless
the united first
you